[Applause]
welcome adjudication I'm Kevin Smith I'm
anemic Alfred hey oh my god we've got a
bunch of [ __ ] stuff to give away man
we got some fabulous prizes we got some
tremendous [ __ ] questions
we Andy and I analyzed the game tape of
the last time we did this which was the
first time we did this last week man and
we perfected it gone our [ __ ] dice and
boxes and [ __ ] like that
now when there's a tie there's more
[ __ ] questions and you'll come up here
and have to duke it out with somebody
who ever answers you don't clicks the
thing fastest well when Andy built this
technology in himself I did I printed it
to look exactly like the one you might
buy on Amazon it's [ __ ] phenomenal ok
so before we get started how are you
good sir oh very well I thank you dealt
with a flooded basement all day but
other than that I'd caught hantavirus
and have black mold in my lungs but
everything else is great
I went to Comic Con so same [ __ ]
thing just got back Comic Con was
absolutely lovely well I got back late
last night after we had a babylon show
at night and then I just decided to
drive home rather than fight with the
traffic we're ready to [ __ ] do this
man we have got ten rounds of questions
this time that wanted more questions so
easily the biggest complaint was people
like it was too fast weren't enough
questions so we said alright we'll
[ __ ] double it which means we have 10
rounds of [ __ ] fabulous prizes and
whatnot where's our prize container can
you drag that over here between us it's
so heavy because there's so little booty
is in it oh yes Oh God look at it all we
got broad seas we got pops we got
[ __ ] tickets for experiences and [ __ ]
like that movie posters costumes from
yoga hosers
weed products and [ __ ] like that it's
not so much we got to get legacy Kevin
Smith t-shirts that's that I can attest
to having done many a podcasts staring
across the desk at that chess
protector they're now going out to fans
that's right one of our rounds is called
tease me baby and it's all of my old fat
guy shirts so I've rolled up three and
you could pretty much tent a house with
three of them they're very very large
but they're cool work in the termite
business you this will be something
you'll need AB you will absolutely and
you'll recognize them if you're a fan of
the DXL stores they all come from there
and ok but but enough with the [ __ ]
prizes let's dive the [ __ ] into it show
me we got ten rounds of questions all
the cards everyone got cards are ready
and we have the cards they need everyone
right pens all ready as well last week
with NF pens that got fixed last week we
read the rules and then this week I'm
like [ __ ] it's a pub quiz [ __ ] the
rules so the rules are posted somewhere
online or and but you know it's not
there's nothing like Dyer it's not like
we get to the end and you have to take
your pants off or something like that
it's just instead of going through the
rules we might I should add all
questions have been verified by three
different sources but those sources are
all on the Internet
yes so example what would look like a
modern and accurate Godzilla height
chart turns out to be three months out
of date yeah and II lost a lot of sleep
over this one right one of the questions
last week was about the height of
Godzilla and one person I think on the
internet was like that's technically not
true they released new figures like last
week if it was only one and II was there
was more than one I only saw one oh I
got lots of direct messages I got a lot
of people there just like hey man it may
not have been released in the United
States but it was a good movie and they
were jumping on it I'll tell you why I
picked the question because I think it's
just hilarious that they're like hey we
made a new Godzilla movie and this guy's
taller than the last guy I'm like what
difference does it make all the monsters
are the same height I think at the end
of the day they're like this one's just
like the last one but this time he's
bigger all right I think that's how
they're selling that movie the predator
they're like remember the predator
you're like yeah they're like this one's
bigger a predator
okay so don't give Andy [ __ ] is what
he's getting at yes everyone has to deal
with imagine most of the [ __ ] you were
given were by people that weren't even
here that is correct
don't take sweat from those people why
would you lose a second of your day to
somebody bitching about a pop quiz they
didn't [ __ ] attend it's because it's
my relentless strive for perfection
well let's ever fall word man we got ten
rounds of new [ __ ] questions and the
edge of a pub quiz is about to begin put
your hands together for pop okay first
round is the Terry Fox prep round these
questions have to do with high school
movies and or TV shows Terry Fox prep
was the high school in yoga hosers and
stuff so we do a round themed around
that because the prizes are three
complete Terry Fox prep uniforms as
screen seen in the movie yoga hosers now
you're sitting there going if nobody saw
it did it exist yes it [ __ ] happened
and these costumes were in it and you'll
be able to walk away with your team what
with which team members are one two five
it's one two five members of a team you
can have a team of up to five right just
so you know you may not have seen it but
I was in yoga hosers I played the art
critic and these gym suits have more
screen time than I did yeah so for this
round we're the winning team will walk
away with a small medium and large Terry
Fox prep could Jim sue scarcely there's
a t-shirt and shorts they say Terry Fox
grab on once you win them they're yours
you can [ __ ] wear them if you like
you can give them to a friend you could
try to eBay them good [ __ ] luck I
tried you could they are yours to do
with as you wish here we go get your
cards out get your pens up now what high
school movie are we covering this time
it looks like according to the thing
I've just been handed the high school
movie that we're going to be asking
questions about this week is wait for it
The Breakfast Club ladies and gentlemen
let's start things nice and easy
everyone I got this aced and [ __ ] like
this this is the easy round here we go
number one pens up get ready of all the
actors in The Breakfast Club only one
went on to star in a six season drama
series name the show so what are the
actors from The Breakfast Club went on
to star in a six year long hour-long
drama series what was the name of that
show I'm sorry I just [ __ ] said I
know I'm repeating it oh yes absolutely
and unlike last episode where we
repeated the question like three [ __ ]
times this time we're only gonna do it
two and move the [ __ ] on here we go
second question second question second
question what does bender catch in his
mouth while sitting at his table in
detention is somebody hissing me in the
library scene in the library they're all
in the library man this guy for once
again bender
catches something in his mouth yes what
is it what could it be
ah The Breakfast Club I have a script
for The Breakfast Club back in my office
that I believe I will bring in and will
be a prize on one of the weeks this is
honestly I love doing this quiz and
stuff but it's an excellent excuse for
me to clean out my office I'm a hoarder
and I have a real hard time just
throwing things out everyone's always
like just [ __ ] throw it out I'm like
I can't do you know how long it took me
to get to this [ __ ] thing and there's
a story attached and people walk away
because they don't want to hear instead
but here it allows me to collect a bunch
of things and bring in an award as
prizes for people who might actually
enjoy or appreciate them so it's like I
get to give them two hands that care yes
and I don't just throw them out so you
know what would what night would have
been perfect to bring your Breakfast
Club script tonight yes
[Applause]
fair enough okay third question Ally
Sheedy 'he's character draws a picture
what does she use to make snow if you
don't [ __ ] get this get out right now
famous famous very famous scene man ally
she'd he's character draws a picture
what does she use to make the snow here
we go no calling out that we didn't
literally ask you sir everybody fourth
question what assignment must each of
the kids in detention complete they're
all given an assignment yes they must
complete it in order to satisfy the
terms of their detention it's the thrust
of the movie one might say it's the plot
point upon which the whole [ __ ]
picture pivots what assignment must each
of these kids in detention complete and
your last question in category number
one round one the Terry Fox round number
five here we go what is the name of the
band that sings The Breakfast Club theme
now Andy has the question writer can you
what is that what do you mean what is
the Breakfast Club theme the song that
plays at the end titles of the movie
don't you forget about you we're not
giving them the title of the song oh
[ __ ] it's known as The Breakfast Club
theme yes what is the name of the band
what is the name of the band it's known
as The Breakfast Club theatres it is
known if you look up Breakfast Club team
on the internet you will get that song
well that's not what it's called them
the credits now I feel like a person on
the internet calling you out but that's
not what it says on it's a fine-tuned
question we now know exactly what's
behind it whose name the [ __ ] band is
really the question maybe we should post
the rules because this feels Byzantine
alright last time what is the name of
the band that sings what Andy calls The
Breakfast Club song The Breakfast Club
soon we'll be in detention at your gym
you got a future at jingles there it is
folks five questions round one put your
hands in the air with your card and Big
Daddy or Nate or maybe even cat ears
will collect your cards from you when
you're done throw your cards up soon as
all the cards are collected we will go
over the answers all cars go in we have
a card over here at Table nine I just
make up the table numbers uh let's
speculate on the round as we're waiting
as the cards go in that was I would say
a moderately difficult round I think I
would have gotten three easily out of
five now you're thinking the average is
gonna be four yes if you could get three
the average person is gonna get four I
bet you most of the cards are gonna come
back with four something tells me
there'll be a couple competitors yeah at
the end of round ready to play off in
the thunderdome
yes all right have we gotten all the
cards collected is that working with
underdog no more cards out any other
cards hands up if you have a card
okay wait ninety I see a card right
there they're all conferring oh look at
the Internet and fill out your form that
is against the rules whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa are you looking at the Internet
[Laughter]
I guess we need to go over the rules a
little bit ladies and gentleman like
every [ __ ] test you ever [ __ ] it take
in your life if you cheat you will
[ __ ] lose we don't ask these
questions for you to go look them up on
the internet that's an T already did
that part we need you to provide the
answers without looking at the internet
so these questions you can't be like oh
let me look it up of course not phones
are supposed to be down while this is
going on
do I take pictures and [ __ ] like that
please do it between rounds but you
cannot consult anybody consult your
teammates but you cannot consult
technology to get the answer in this
room there is no technology was that
[ __ ] room like a cage it's called a
Faraday cage this is like a [ __ ]
Faraday cage man although all the power
would yeah but like it's it's four
phones it is like a Thunderdome so
please don't look at your phones and
stuff okay all cards are in all cards
all right let's do the answers beautiful
where are the answers I have the banners
right here sir if you want to how about
I'm gonna try to answer them on my own
and you okay let you let me know number
one of all the actors in The Breakfast
Club only one one on to star in a sixth
season drama series name the show I'm
going to [ __ ] I honestly a drama series
I don't know what is it why it's Anthony
Michael Hall in the dead zone oh yes
that is deep cuts man quality question
[ __ ] whenever he touches someone he can
see how they die yes that's the premise
yeah and the other show on USA that was
also in the top ten was monk where a guy
that does not like to be touched so they
had a little thing going there
oh how [ __ ] interesting okay number
two what does bender catch in his mouth
while sitting at his table I would say
his own loogie right he catches his own
spit we will accept spit loogie [ __ ]
yeah okay number three Ally Sheedy 'he's
character draws a picture what does she
used to make snow I believe the answer
is
it's dandruff not about a fluids and
flakes in this quiz no doubt number 4
what assignment must each of the kids in
detention complete it's a one thousand
word essay saying who they think they
are so is that the full answer you can
take s a thousand words who are who am I
will take any of those as the answer but
that is the the gist of it they have to
do a written assignment and it becomes
the narration of the movie that's very
true and for the final question in this
round was what is the name of the band
that sings what Andy calls The Breakfast
Club theme your breakfast club day
you're talking about don't you forget
about me don't you yeah forget about the
name of the [ __ ] song not the
Breakfast Club theme and [ __ ] you just
made that [ __ ] up that would be like me
saying that the immigrant song is the
Thor song like that's it's not but still
you were absolutely right you were
asking for the name of the band and you
didn't need to know what the name of the
song was to know the name of the band
the name of the band that sings the song
that ends The Breakfast Club that Andy
calls The Breakfast Club theme is simple
mine's absolutely didn't forget about
them all right I believe I saw card come
in that's right ladies and gentlemen of
all of the teams here at the pub quiz
tonight one no that's only if they get
the answers right one of them got all
five questions correct that's it so they
won't face anybody this is the true
winner of the round true winner of the
round and the ladies and gentlemen
you're gonna see something that has
never happened on education thus far
each round last time we had two people
competing against each other this is the
first time that one person got all five
right one team is gonna walk away with a
bag full of [ __ ] Terry Fox prep
school uniforms smell like the [ __ ]
actors that warm ladies and my put your
hands together for doublemeat palace
guards guards come on send a represent
somebody up to accept your prize
ladies and gentlemen what's your name my
friend Lanny everyone give it up for
Lanny she's a [ __ ] when are we're
heading into round two ladies gentlemen
wrap right along there's so many
questions in this game there's gonna be
a lot more it's an orgy of [ __ ]
questions round two is tease me baby
this is the round where you're gonna win
some old fat cat shirts man do with them
what you want and whatnot
the questions are themed to the letter T
hence tease me baby and this week
the questions are themed specifically to
the a-team for mr. t yeah so these are
questions about the a-team having to do
with mr. team so you need a fairly
decent working knowledge of the a-team
which I'll admit right now I I did not
have this round I would totally you will
find that there are questions that have
to do with the opening titles of the
show that are repeated every single
episode so you may do better than you
think
fair enough here we go ladies and
gentlemen get your pens up put your
[ __ ] phones down and get ready to
answer these questions smarten up tease
me round 2 question 1 what does the BA
in ba Baracus stand for they've got it
yeah I would get this one yeah I knew
this one what does the ba and ba Baracus
stand for and I will give a clue it is
not bachelor of arts not Bachelor of
Arts I hear a bunch of a racing going on
in cards right now here we go question
number two folks who played ba Baracus
in the 2010 feature film version of the
a-team was that the one with Liam Neeson
sure was man Liam Neeson directed by joe
carnahan yeah i believe it has a scene
where there's a tank on a parachute
descending and he's [ __ ] firing guns
from and that's how they steer it
they steer it by shooting the gun in the
opposite direction fantastic one last
time who played ba Baracus in the 2010
feature film for
version of the a-team ladies and
gentlemen question three what was B A's
rank in the army before he was
court-martialed I have no idea in the
Army they called him by his rank on the
show frequently so that is why fair
enough man that question again ladies
and gentlemen what was B A's rank in the
army
before he was court-martialed the
court-martialing always happened
pre-series right like they never did a
flashback lives in the LA underground
yeah and if you needed help and you
could find them then just maybe you
could get the a-team do you think at the
end of the day the a-team like since
they never showed like what if what the
backstory
they never did an episode where they
were flashback where mr. T had a full
head of hair and [ __ ] and like you saw
the crime actually do they talk about it
in the opening titles of the show I
understand that they never did I don't
know it's not like Magnum where they go
back so my feeling is that you could
argue they're the a-team like them on
the run and [ __ ] them like we're [ __ ]
being hunted by the government could
have just been in their [ __ ] minds
wow you know that would be a more
interesting a-team I would watch that
version of the a-team where they're like
just paranoid delusions we got to go I
know like why why there's no one here
next question what was the character
name and rank of Dirk Benedict's
recurring series TV role before the
a-team he was a famous character on a TV
series before the 18th this is a very
convoluted question so we'll break it
down and diagram it like you do in high
school what was the name of the
character name and rank
not just the character's name but his
rank that Dirk Benedict his character
his recurring character played on a TV
series role before he was on the a-team
now when it comes to Dirk Benedict roles
on TV there aren't two that is correct
many this you should be lots of Love
Boat cameos but that's not what we're
talking about we're talking about that
show that came before certain if you're
here this coming
lynnie cantina I have a feeling you
might be familiar with what that show
was that's absolutely correct speaking
of which we are here live at the scum
and villainy Cantina and Hollywood on
Hollywood Boulevard ladies a job and we
got a pretty good crowd for a comic-con
weekend most people are still in San
Diego and whatnot but we got some decent
sized crowd here tonight there's a
pretty good crowd for a comic-con Billy
Joel now's okay last question ladies
gentlemen round two what crime did the
a-team commit under orders what was the
crime in quotes sarcastic air quotes did
the a-team commit under orders is that
true that yeah they were ordered to go
commit a crime and then double-crossed
oh that's unfair no wonder they were
[ __ ] yeah righteous and [ __ ] yeah
that's right I should have watched an
episode I was never into that show you
just have to watch one they're all the
same there it is folks the last year
questions what crime did the a-team
commit under orders when you are done
filling out your card for round two put
it in the air and we're with the co
helpers gum cow deers or Big Daddy G BB
or Nate are gonna collect those cards
for me they're gonna tabulate it will
let you know who is gonna win cards in
the corner did you do your card yet oh
you didn't play that one you're like now
just not enough a-team in that noggin
huh anybody else no more cards up we got
cards over here
big smile on the face of that card hand
er cards that be the winning card that
she just handed over could be if you've
if you've handed in your cards feel free
to look at the Internet at that point if
you've handed it in your cards but if
you wait just a few seconds we're gonna
give you them I'll tell you what those
answers are are all the cards in any
outstanding cards no more cards all
right let's go to the answers Kevin okay
cards in ladies gentlemen here we go the
answers to this round what does the BA
and ba Baracus stand for I'm gonna say
bad attitude bad attitude
bad attitude it was either that or big
ass I went for bad at its well number
two who played ba in the 2010 feature
film version of the a-team who was it it
was one time
Randy Jack so rampage taxon rampage yes
his full name is Quinton Rampage Jackson
he's a Mitch mixed martial arts uh
he's you up Schneider rampage dr.
breslar crazy Jack the movie he was
pretty good in the movie too he was a
mr. t when it came to acting what was B
A's ranked in the army before he was
court-martialed
I don't know this what is this sergeant
we got sergeants over here yes sergeant
first class or sergeant would be
acceptable seems like a lot of people
miss that one man let go [ __ ]
number four what was the character name
and rank of Dirk Benedict's recurring TV
series role before the a-team well we
all know the series it would be
Battlestar Galactica circle ax guy he
would be Starbuck he was Starbuck but I
don't know what his Colonel Starbuck he
was lieutenant Starbucks because all the
pilots were lieutenants they all got
their lieutenants bars at the beginning
of the series so the answer we were
looking for is lieutenant star blue
Bennet lieutenant Starbuck and you
wouldn't have just accepted Starbuck we
need lieutenant Starbuck well I mean if
you want to accept it we can do that but
I think it but it does yes I think the
rank is important fair enough I fan you
would have known then the last question
in the round ladies and gentlemen what
crime did the a-team commit under orders
I don't know this man what did they do
well they were ordered to rob the bank
of Hanoi of all its gold to bring about
the end of the Vietnam War early so
we'll take robbery gold heist bank theft
stealing just anything having to do with
ripping off a bank so it was a robbery
yes and then they were double-crossed
their commander was murdered and they
had to go on the run there are your
answers for round two ladies gentlemen
here are your suite fabulous prizes this
is a Green Lantern shirt from
as well male DXL store sized for excel
it's a lot of [ __ ] shirt it could be
worn like a nightshirt or it could cover
the entire bed this is a flash shirt
also from casual male DXL I'm not sure
what the size is because I ripped the
tag of the tag out in shame and then
this this is another Green Lantern shirt
this is a Justice League of America
shirt this one's also for Excel and
stuff so there you go three gigantic all
have been sanitized for your protection
yes they've all been washed and wrapped
with a clean rubber band yes we have a
winner the round our boy our team is
really working fast this week so wait
what up we already know who won that
round so nobody's fighting nobody is
fighting again lone winner one lone do
one lone winner get all the answers
correct no only four I walk us through
it before you give us the name build it
up you know Kayla - okay well they did
get bad attitude and they knew he was a
sergeant lieutenant Starbuck see people
know that one yeah and robbery was their
answer for number five but they instead
of instead of Rampage Jackson they put
matumbo Kim be if you're gonna if you're
gonna lose lose big man that's a good
guy yeah fair enough who is the winning
team Andy well right now they're sitting
pretty with two round wins it's
doublemeat palace guard oh sure
doublemeat palace guards ladies and
gentlemen what's your name good sir oh
that don't work what's your name good
sir I'm Eric Eric who's the smart one on
the team or is it a group effort she's
lucky she's a smart one on the team but
I needed some 4x shirts as you can see
you're a winner give it up for a man
great job round three ladies and
gentlemen your cards they'll get you
pens up we're about to start round three
and round three is the brats around in
round three if you win this round you
are going to walk away with a brats e a
screen-used prop from a motion picture
man and this brats II pull that bag for
me
whoa looks like that oh look at that it
was in a movie I swear yes so that's
gonna be the prize whoo somebody's gonna
walk away with that as we get into round
three round three the brats around is
monster questions ladies and gentlemen
all the questions have to do with
monsters theatrical monster cinematic
monsters yes TV monsters mostly bigger
than this monster but not as big as the
latest Godzilla that one haunts you Dino
does here we go
question one number one for round three
the brats around ready pens up ladies
and gentlemen here we go
phones down what this is a great
question what's the name of the flower
shop in Little Shop of Horrors to hear
that guy alright great quiet Rick
Moranis that was many times that's a
good pull man I like that question I
would get this one right what is the
name of the flower shop in Little Shop
of Horrors flower shop in Little Shop of
Horrors like that yes you go downtown
number two Guillermo del Toro has
directed two sequels in his career
Hellboy 2 and what was the other film
another sequel directed by Guillermo del
Toro that was not Hellboy to figure that
out write it down you could win a
[ __ ] Brasi could be yours
number three what classic movie monster
had his own my god I read that so
yeah like a felt like the president what
classic movie monster had his own
Saturday morning cartoon with a theme
song that described him as ten times as
big as a man what what classic movie
monster had his own Saturday morning
cartoon with a theme song that described
him as ten times as big as a man and it
ran on WPIX channel 11 when you were a
kid with Hercules as one of the
half-hours and the show was the other
hmm I don't know I wouldn't get this one
right okay it's not ringing any bells
think of a big monster that is ten times
as big as a man I can think of a bunch
and I can think of something that had a
Saturday morning cartoons but I don't
remember that as part of the lyrics so I
don't think it's the one I'm thinking of
all right number three what special
effects makeup artist won an Oscar for
his work in an American Werewolf in
London looking for the special effects
makeup guy who created the werewolf look
everything in the zombie look for let's
not confuse him in American Werewolf in
London right that his friend was killed
and he turns he did all this but all of
the special effects in American Werewolf
in London who did those special effects
this guy won an Oscar form let us know
who that is
man that was number four number five in
the movie FX whoo this deep cuts I would
never get this in the movie FX what is
the name of the monster by the door
classic one you got to read that quick
all right you're slow the name of the
monster by the door it's a classic movie
reference that Brian Brown's character
uses to demonstrate the gun effect of
how he's gonna kill the mobster so right
by the front door you open the door and
this monster goes roar and scares
everybody and later in the movie he does
the five shots to the four shots to the
body and one to the head and it's a
classic movie reference because the
movie is all about other movie
references there's hundreds of movie
references and the movie effects in the
movie effects and this is a very famous
one and he mentions the name three times
could they remake FX today or would it
just be people running around in green
body yes
just be that the movie effects was
predicated on our hero was a
special-effects artist in movies so they
used a lot of that to help him get him
out of a jam and she and the witness
protection program had him fake kill
someone to have them basically hide from
being killed I forgot about that last
chance and the movie effects what's the
name of the monster by the door it's
classic movie reference that Brian
Brown's character uses to demonstrate
the gun effects to the u.s. marshals
what's the giant monster by the door in
FX lady it's a monster all right here we
go that's it I take live questions or
questions time to hand in the your card
round three is up ladies if you have to
take a shot at it anybody else got round
three cards coming in round three cards
coming in if you finished your cards
they gentlemen hold them up in there Big
Daddy Jimmy V or cat ears or Nate is
gonna pick them up go back right
tabulate and find out who wins approxi
we can't talk over each other okay it's
okay
who is gonna win the brats see any other
cards over in this corner everybody done
handing in those cards folks cards go in
because the answers are about to come
out once you got your cards handed in if
you need to look at your phone feel free
to look at your phone all cards in a lot
of people on the phones I'm guessing all
the cards are in okay let's uh close on
the round in five four three two one
it's over ladies John let's find out
what the [ __ ] going on with the right
what's the name of the flower shop in
Little Shop of Horrors
mushnick Busch Knicks mr. Mushnik mr.
Mushnik we got so much Knicks over here
Guillermo del Toro has directed two
sequels this one stumped me Hellboy 2
and what other film Blade 2 zu ba
thought about he did not do the original
one as good one that Ricky did stump me
what classic movie monster has owned
Saturday morning cartoon with a theme
song that describes him as
10 times as big as a man King Kong you
know the name of King Kong ten times as
big as a man I remember that when I was
trying to I was thinking of the Godzilla
cartoon I was like those lyrics aren't
in it at all and then I thought about
King Kong but I'm like that cartoon
didn't have a theme song but apparently
it sure did and the end King Kong rips
off the top of a volcano and the lava
pours down and forms the letters King
Kong oh my god do you were fans that's a
big fan all right number four what
special effects makeup artist won an
Oscar for his work in an American
Werewolf in London I'm gonna say Rick
Baker's like Rick Baker indeed rumored
to have been one of the Star Wars
Cantina musicians oh good at it yeah in
the [ __ ] Wow
Rick Baker's who I wanted to be when I
was a kid man I wanted to be long before
I was like I want to make films I want
it to be a special effects makeup artist
I love Tim I love Tom Savini and stuff
like that so yeah that question near and
dear to my heart and in the movie FX
what's the name of the monster by the
door
anybody rosebud it was rosebud what's
that that's the movie right the sled
from that's what he shot was a sled no
no it was a monster named rosebud named
after the sled from wow the deep I mean
you wanted everyone to lose on that one
that's almost like asking people what am
I thinking right now well just know it's
more like imagine how great they would
have felt if they'd gotten it I don't
know I bet you you could ask the
director of FX it had been like I don't
know that I give a [ __ ]
let's hear about it who is our winner
sir well you know it may come as a
surprise to you yes that with four
correct answers they did not get
question number five they put wolf man
instead of the wolf and is in that movie
is there any way to know if anyone got
nobody got that answer based on the
amount of hatred
on me near the room it really went out
of its way to [ __ ] everybody man fair
enough
do we have more than one winner in this
round no more than one winner again what
is going on sailing like Christopher
Cross why was last week there was like
so many [ __ ] uh multiple winners in
this week none mathematically is there a
reason or it's just the people they just
don't know that's what yeah Oh out of
town right now all right fair enough we
got one winner for this round
tell us what team it is and it's that
team would be bantha fodder send up a
representative bantha fodder what's your
name good sir it's everyone get the
phone over here give it up for Aaron and
bantha fodder what what are you gonna do
with this where will this go how will a
team share this scare children in my
neighborhood nice and what everyone gets
it for a week a month or something yeah
we shared or you could just cut it up
into like five pieces
regardless it's yours do it as you wish
give it up for bantha fodder lazy guys
[Applause]
okay next round ladies and gentlemen is
the raw round raw round man the good
folks at raw rollin products send me a
bunch of weed related stuff and so boom
we got a prize package here with a sweet
rolling tray man a rolling ten there's
some wraps and there's a doob tube
something to put your joint in when it's
[ __ ] rolled up often though good
folks at raw man so if you're a smoker
you're gonna love it if you're not a
smoker making it so the wheat smokers
life convenient always always make it
easy as possible so here we go
it is around four full of weed related
questions and question number one is
here we go Blake Shelton of the voice
wrote and performed a song about pot
what's the title Blake Shelton not
really this crowds a favorite I'm
guessing
me neither I mean now that I don't live
out I'm like [ __ ] you yeah he got a
country song about going home and
smoking weed
well now I'm interested in this pledge
yes man I might have to sample some of
his words Blake Shelton is a guy that's
sang about weed wants apparently enough
for me okay number two what here we go
number two watch your voices folks here
we go clear the room and clear the room
shut up
what twenty twelve Willie Nelson song
about weed features vocals by Snoop Dogg
this was a another country anthem very
popular it actually charted twelve
Willie Nelson sings about weed and it
features vocals by a young Snoop Dogg
man what is that song it was 2012 it's
[ __ ] six years ago technically that's
young okay I take it if that FX question
plays so does my young snoop comment
okay wow I've I was on the internet I
would give you more [ __ ] about pet than
you got for King Kong well thank you
looking forward to it okay here we go
number three sixteen years before
starring in Cape Fear what famous actor
spent six months in jail for marijuana
possession they don't qualify it just
let it live there man good repeat the
question exactly as I will repeat that
question in I'll do it six sixty years
before starring in Cape Fear what famous
actor spent six months in jail for
marijuana possession
all right now we're going onto question
before number four which house in Harry
Potter is rumored to be the stoner house
yes I could take a guess it is you can
see some Potter fans really whipping out
the pens on that one everyone's gonna
get this one correct which house and
Harry Potter is rumored to be the stoner
house and the last question in round
four ladies gentlemen the raw round weed
related here we go what hawaiian village
famous for strong weed is referenced in
Puff the Magic Dragon spelling does not
count just if you can get the village
name right from the song Puff the Magic
Dragon it is yet one of the many pot
references that Peter Paula Murray
claimed they did not make I I know the
answer to this but I did not know that
that it was a Hawaiian village it is Wow
what Hawaiian Village famous for strong
weed is referenced in Puff the Magic
Dragon and that is the end of your round
for the raw round ladies and gentlemen
that's all the questions we did it we
completed it around put your hands
together yes nicely done we finished
something hands up cards in the bar is
low here in any sense of completion is a
good thing accomplishment we finished
the round
cards in the air give them out to
carriers we'll pick them up Big Daddy
Jimmy V Nate will collect them they'll
go tabulate and Professor Andrew McHale
fresh not a real professor will tell us
the answers all right as we got all the
cards cards up and if we got any cards
left all good on cards here we go cards
are in rounds about to close in five oh
you have your cards for no we have to
read it got card guys - one more one and
we're done okay number one in Raw round
Blake Shelton of The Voice wrote and
performed a song about pot what's the
title Andy it's called ready to roll
really ready to roll is talking about
rolling up joints and smoking them with
your pals I am going to Spotify this
song on my way
home.what 2012 willie nelson's song
about weed features vocals by Snoop Dogg
that would be Roly up and smoked me when
I die roll me up and smoke me when I die
I'm addict got to my Spotify playlist on
the way home if you didn't get it right
it was worth here in that answer no
doubt man
our level of respect has just jumped for
both of those artists sixteen years
before starring in Cape Fear what famous
actors spent six months in jail for
marijuana possession now this was a
trick question of sorts that's true
because Cape Fear did have a remake and
that maybe more top of mind and make it
feel like there's some weed involved
that's right but it was actually the
original Cape Fear and it was the scary
guy himself Robert Mitchum
Robert Mitchum was arrested for weed
possession it was a nine-month
government sting operation to catch a
big fish and they got Robert Mitchum
with it they got Mitchum they landed
mitch Utley loaded him like a Marlin I
know a lot of people out there with a
good Cape Fear it must be Robert De Niro
[ __ ] that's why I was like don't [ __ ]
say anything [ __ ] because I knew that -
Cape Fear I knew this generation
particularly would never remember the
[ __ ] other Cape Fear in scale by the
way I'm wearing my Mitchum what is that
oh is that there's a deodorant called
Mitchum yes you could tell I don't use
any of the other well I didn't need you
to it right here we go what house and
Harry Potter is rumored to be the stoner
house someone shout it out everybody
knew that man whoever wrote Slytherin
doesn't understand weed and lastly what
Hawaiian Village famous for strong weed
is referenced in Puff the Magic Dragon
as Andy pointed out the spelling didn't
count
an intelligent count because in the song
how do you say it Hanalei is the name of
the village but holily is what they say
in the song so we didn't want to make a
spelling count right so that's where a
little Jacky paper left that rascal
puffs oh my god Jacky paper like rolling
paper that song is all about weed why
did they deny it for so long
I don't know I think because it would've
been banned from the air you think
they're just bad for the air like banned
from the airwaves the MC ruled I guess
they didn't hear [ __ ] roll me up and
smoke me when I'm dead it was a
different time very very true
alright there's your raw round ladies
and gentlemen there's all your answers
we're still waiting for a little
tabulation so while we'll do that we'll
play a quick mini game right here is a
license plate used in the movie yoga
hosers it's a fake Manitoba license
plate man this ain't real not at all
it's [ __ ] made-up for movies and you
could walk away with this if you answer
a question wow that's a lot what is the
question they're gonna answer give me
the blue one that's good look [ __ ]
what is give me five songs that have the
word blue in them put your hand up if
you want to play five songs we're
blowing them anybody's five songs blue
in the title you're bang right there go
Oh blue velvet number one hand clapping
number two I can't tell you that song
ma'am I have to you have to win it come
on man someone else who wants to I see
hand in the back so he head into that
corner see what happens right there five
songs have word blue in it ready go
number one number two number three
number four she did it give it up man
you win a fake license plate somebody
sent it back to her well done excellent
[ __ ] job
look you [ __ ] won something put that
on the back of your car and go commit
crimes okay Andy I see your your fist
holding a lot of cards what's going on
what's going on is that well we've been
pretty lucky and only one team has won
each of the rounds previous yes eight
teams tied
so we're gonna have to do to run off
questions okay and we're gonna do two
rounds of where I'll have questions and
then the final question so this is
exciting as [ __ ] now tell us how we're
gonna do that let's get first we'll get
the team one member of each team to come
up we need swedish fish
Oreos Top Gun bantha fodder and
Voldemort oh yeah I just have to hit him
out an order there you go perfect
yeah right no I just had to just do all
right so we'll do it I need one
representative from each winning team
you also were on the winning team as
well oh you want a license plate and you
bite wins the [ __ ] week oh yeah happy
work absolutely yeah if your sentence
begins with I'm not the strongest always
[ __ ] pass off to the we have it we
have one person from Voldemort who's
that one person from Baltimore
don't touch one person from bantha
fodder come on up step up one person
from Swedish Fish Oreos Oreo sweet
especially owes nobody well hold on
there's only four people playing right
no no this is a you having a lot of
issues with this round ma'am so you guys
know no person to go it but we do need
one more player grand top gun so your
top cards here's one player what it's
your team and so we need Voldemort Valda
Mort well buddy weren't anybody from
that team or did you guys quit all right
Baltimore you've lost your chance to
play are you all right there fall or 15
yes I didn't realize the red number 14
other Voldemort's here tonight sir yeah
all right here we go explain what's
gonna happen here Andy so we're gonna
ask a question and the first to know it
hits their hits their little indicator
and it'll tell us who it was by the
light that's on this on these eggs once
there once and the person if they get it
right then they win this round and
everyone else sits down if they get
wrong then somebody else can ring in and
get the and try to get the answer okay
so the first question for weed
what is the latin name of weed folks we
need quiet over here please marijuana
you know these words they are used all
the time
Latin name of we have no takers he's
pressing a button look nothing's
happening well this is a this has never
happened to me before so well let's go
with you what do you have Voldemort
cannabis is correct so he wins the round
whoa wait a second what what hold on he
would win the round if anything worked
but like I don't think it's fair to be
like anyone else nobody else knew the
answer so nobody so I'm gonna just
switch these out and we'll use see if
this one works
that won't work but nobody else knew the
answer so I'm going to have an album oh
don't keep keep testing it let's get it
right okay that worked okay that worked
hit that one that really works yeah you
know what you won the round man give it
up firm you walk away what's your name
my friend Shannon oh my god you're gonna
walk away with this sweet ass train all
this rail raw product give it up for him
he's a [ __ ] champion man okay we are
heading into round five ladies and
gentlemen round five is the education
round man and the education right oh
wait there's still other people we got
to do yeah we do a forum or other people
and then I'm just because we have eight
wait so that guy didn't win no he
doesn't when he wins his the semi the
four people come up and then the tube
that went play against each other
holy [ __ ] this guy what semi are you
talking about that I we don't have eight
we can't play eight against one I know
but he just walked away with the prize
all right well we'll we'll talk to the
other teams after the game and I'll make
it right okay who are the other teams
that were up for the running the other
teams were team Mercurian the 37 Club
movie Pucci calm
and pillow pants so throw three others
for others so afterwards just come and
see me let's let's do it right bring the
four other teams up here maybe look at
another prize to breed the names again
read the okay let's get somebody from
pillow pants hold the huh hold on folks
listen go hello pants movie poop shoot
calm the 37 club and team Mercurian we
got everyone represented here so let's
test these buttons one turn it on one
second oh we're gonna try this [ __ ]
again yeah it's we did we practice with
this last night everything worked
perfectly
just let me here we go try green okay
let's have somebody call in when they
have it yes hit the bar like that
[ __ ] technology we'll do it the way the
Luddites do it okay okay move that [ __ ]
out the way man [ __ ] irritating here
we go okay I know if I can get your
money back here we did you buy it at
Amazon I know people here we go get
ready to slap the counter okay
what's the it's also we we're doing more
weed questions okay and what you're
gonna be playing for more importantly
since the he won the practice you're
playing for a green screen brats II
that's right yeah right you're sitting
there gone oh this is better yeah yes
one of you will be winning this fine
one-of-a-kind green screen brats see
which we used to make yoga hosers for
the special effects read that would make
a great team name
sure what the question is what chemical
does cannabis release it bag no I'm
sorry
hold on hold on hold on alright everyone
be quiet here we go three contestants
left get ready to bang in the quest
whole question is what chemical does
cannabis release in the brain it
releases a chemical in the brain right
there no I'm sorry that's incorrect your
left chemical makes you feel good it's
anybody know I'm sorry that's not
correct
three
losers what weight doesn't even have to
respond well I guess he's not out but do
you have an answer for us spoken like a
true stoner we have another question if
you want to just ask them all again
let's do another question but give us
the answer the answer is dopamine ladies
and gentlemen - oppa man very famous
dopamine why do you think pick another
question get ready to slam in ok what
ingredient in beer is closely related to
the marijuana plant right there hops you
win the game
what's your name man John but up for him
he's a [ __ ] winner ok
[Applause]
alright that took a little longer than
expected but we got through it man
technology failed us but our wits our
wits is what says this is round
speaking of wits we're heading into the
round after which the whole [ __ ]
podcast his name this is the education
round ladies and gentlemen round 5 grab
those books in the education round your
team will win one of potentially five
signed copies of the book edumacation
written by Professor Andrew McElveen
give it up for Andy he wrote a book this
is what your team is playing four or
five copies of the book ladies and
gentlemen all the questions come from
our derives from facts from the
education podcast on the podcast you
have if you've listened to the show
you've heard these facts before here we
go number one pens up get ready what
common body part comes from the Latin
for little mouse try to keep it clean
what common body part comes from the
Latin for little mouse number two what
does the word avocado mean in the Aztec
language Nahuatl Nahuatl nawafil Nahuatl
can't believe I got that right nicely
done what does the word avocado mean in
the Aztec language Nahuatl
it is descriptive and reminiscent of
something oh really yes one of those
words that means something yes because I
remember telling you this on the podcast
what oh my god that's right I should
know this this is the round I would
probably lose the hardest what animal
number three what animal gets its name
from the German for badger warrior what
animal gets its name from the German for
badger warrior I believe the term is
Andy Mikkel fish well the you know it
just to clarify it is now its name it's
common name now it means badger dog yeah
that's your dog okay number four whiskey
comes from the Gaelic oh I can't say
that go ahead whisky bait that whiskey
batha meaning what the word whiskey
comes from the Gaelic term whiskey beta
and whiskey is spelled U is GE be a tha
eight be a e-thas
EA be EA th yes PA meaning what what
does it mean ooh
whiz gets bad let's say it again we
escaped baitha wheeze get beta that
sounds more Russian than gala well it's
what whiskey comes from and if we're in
a bar so people should know what their
what they're getting people like I know
where my whiskey comes from from JC at
the scum and villainy Cantina
number five the last question round five
ladies and gentlemen the education round
the round that demands you use your
[ __ ] brains what TV show gave us the
words yunk craptacular and chrome uhland
television show that we all know and
love gave us the words joint craptacular
and chrome you lint and that's five
questions sir that's the whole round
that is five questions down as soon as
you're done filling out your your card
ladies and gentlemen hold that card up
so one of our fine education volunteers
could collect it put your hands together
for our fine education volunteer
make the show run man Big Daddy Jimmy V
Nate and cat ears once all those cards
are collected we'll go over the answers
this was a tough round man except I know
at least two of the answers and I should
know more because I was there for every
episode of the project but two of them -
a mom certain none now if you're not if
you're sad because you might have
forgotten something
you should just crack open one of these
babies coz the education book has all
kinds of facts to keep make you more
interesting than you are I hate to ask
for more information but where could one
find an education book Andy why the
education book is on sale on amazon.com
or you can buy it in your local book
store it's carried nationwide you've
seen it in a museum I know that made you
very happy yes it's in a lot of museum
gift shops like the American Museum of
Natural History in New York who or the
smart people show and where they shot
right at the museum
Oh with a dumb people go all right here
we go ladies and gentlemen cards all in
counting it down end-of-round in five
four three two one we finished it on the
round put your hands together man we did
it we did it all right Andy tell us
we're gonna say elucidate where are you
I was gonna I was good trying and I was
like don't do it what common body part
comes from the Latin for little mouse
Andy muscle musk for mouse and soul for
small so muscle I did not know that I
was my guess was nipple Wow yeah must go
ladies and gentlemen something that
Popeyes got number two what does the
word avocado mean in the aztec language
of nahuatl all right anybody here know
this one there we go
we got some testicles in the corner
right over there what's the answer
testicles avocado or the worst testicle
yeah Wow because as they hang from the
tree with their wrinkly outsides they
look like deez nuts they look kind of
nuts Wow all right man that's something
to know I'm gonna
imagine I'm gonna take that with me for
the rest of my life but I forgot it the
first time so I'm sure I'll forget it
again but good to know what animal
number three gets its name from the
German for Badger warrior can I take
it's a Daksha dachshund badger hound
dachshund is the answer logo we'd accept
doxy we'd accept world's best dog or
Shecky or Shecky
I'll take Shecky I'll take Chucky no no
one takes Chucky number four whiskey
comes from the Gaelic whiskey baitha
meaning what I mean water of life you
knew that holy [ __ ] well done man well
done water of life is that whiskey means
water of love what a [ __ ] lie that is
number five what TV show gave us the
words yonk craptacular and Carmilla
waetford on the count of three everyone
say it together one two three now let's
all sing it one two three The Simpsons
dooty dooty dooty very good man there
are the answers for your round five
round education round put together by
Andy and Andy I believe has a winner or
more than one I have one winner thank
God I know we don't have to face down in
the egg Ettore oh man [ __ ] like I can't
believe all right what is it what is the
name they got one wrong they did not
know what a little mouse was in Latin I
think everything else right
they put tongue which seemed like a bad
answer not bad and that team was bad the
fodder returns to the winner's circle
hello relations captain what's your name
Brian Brian take those [ __ ] books and
go smarten people up you have 5 people
being a part of Team 5 yeah they're all
yours he won give it up for him ladies
and gentlemen bantha fodder if they do I
have to take five these are heavy all
right round six man get your cards ready
get your pens ready Round six we're in
uncharted territory ladies and gentlemen
we didn't do this category last week
this is a category we like to call
genre gems it's tough to say genre gems
so we say genre gems this week the genre
and
we're gonna be looking at all the
questions relate to the genre of horror
all right horror get your pens up get
your cards ready man here we go question
number one what what what I'm just
waiting for [ __ ] silence what is
James L Brooks is credits name in
treehouse of horror episodes when you
watch The Simpsons Treehouse of Horror
what is the credit that they give to
James L Brooks what do they do with his
name to scarify it they do change it for
the treehouse of horror episode there's
there's one answer there's one answer
it's the same what is James L Brooks
credits name and treehouse of horror
episodes they it's always the same in
every treehouse of our episode here we
go number two in the movie adaptation of
it what significant character is missing
but is referenced in a lego model in
Georgie's room maybe it's a bit that
there's only one referenced in a lego
model but there's a character from the
book that plays an important role and is
not in the movie in the movie adaptation
of hit what's hit it what significant
character is missing but is referenced
in a lego model in Georgie's room yes
yes yeah what it's a current movie will
hurt it movie well well asked yeah this
is a movie adaptation the other one was
a mini-series detective that's true
that's true
that's kuru that's truly kuru true here
we go number three ladies and gentlemen
number three your question number three
quiet silence says sonnet bob james
mcavoy wore a cast in atomic blonde
after breaking his knuckle filming what
horror movie James McAvoy in the movie
atomic bond he's wearing a cast the
whole time he had to wear that because
he busted what a finger he broke a
knuckle broke a knuckle in doing what
horror movie
here we go next question question four
what was Reagan's Regan Regan Regan what
was Reagan's vomit made out of in the
Exorcist
famously I used to know that she used to
know that man let it go for some reason
she's forgotten more about movie vomit
than you'll ever know
what was Reagan's vomit made out of in
the movie The Exorcist and your last
question in round six man these genre
gems are around how many feature films
have been made with Jason from Friday
the 13th as a lead character I need you
to listen to that question very
carefully and we'll say nothing more
than repeat it again and think before
you respond
how many feature films have been made
with Jason from Friday the 13th as a
lead character you tell us the right
answer man you're gonna have a chance to
win something sweet we didn't even do
what the prizes are man I believe the
prize this week for our genre gems round
is a very very sweet jaws poster you
grab onto this you can open it up look
at that [ __ ] it's not a theatrical
poster it's one of those cool artsy
prints it's made by the good folks let
me read this at the bottom ante pitch it
back the good folks at poster by phantom
City creative ink it's gorgeous shows
the Orca heading out to sea to chase
down jaws that is going to be yours if
you answer all these questions correctly
man once your card is filled out hold it
up in the air it'll be collected round
is that an end no more questions left
man throw your hands in the air wave
them like you just don't care make sure
that cat ears or Big Daddy Jimmy V or
Nate grab your cards that go tabulate it
we've got one over here Nate thought oh
there we go cat ears got it
this was a good round of questions man I
would have spent a lot of time thinking
about number five number five is tricky
dicky it's tricky
I mean it's tricky to even without the
trick like just you need to know a lot
about that franchise yeah
all right everyone got their cards in
ladies gentlemen card collection round
is closing in five four three two one oh
my god we finished something put your
hands together it's done it's important
in life to applaud yourself even for the
most menial of tasks once they're
completed number one in these genre gems
category this we ground six horror was
the topic Andy asks us what is James L
Brooks his credits name in the treehouse
of horror episodes Andy tell us james
hell Brooks that's absolutely right
a lot of people got that one in the
movie adaptation of it the movie not the
miniseries what significant character is
missing but is referenced in a lego
model in Georgie's room turtle will take
the turtle or match her in the turtle
what was his name Matt Maturin
Matt Rijn just like in Master and
Commander that's the doctor's name
turtle was the Answer Man number three
James McAvoy wore a cast anatomic blonde
after breaking his knuckle filming what
horror movie split that was my guess it
was let the answer is split ladies I'm
the sequel to which they just dropped
the trailer for online glass and it
looks fantastic looking forward to that
one
the showers Shyamalan asan's continues
number four what was Reagan's vomit made
out of in the Exorcist
pea soup we would take both oatmeal and
pea soup but pea soup is what the
effects artist listed it as in the
safety the answer is P so we will take
people take oatmeal but pea soup is what
Andy was looking that's correct
and number five how many feature films
have been made with Jason from Friday
the 13th as the lead character was
tricky about this folks is that the very
first Friday the 13th movie Jason
Voorhees is
the lead character he's barely a
character at all so that movie doesn't
count he's certainly not the lead
character his mother is the killer and
the movie so what does that leave us
with it leaves us with eleven eleven
films let me read them out to you I'm
all outta here we have our entries
someone get them all yes we have eleven
and that is obviously two through eight
up
well that's I'm sorry that's a type of
there did you can you recorrect the
cards okay we need to just do a Libre
correction I had put a typo in okay but
it's 11 so it's 2 through 8 then Jason
goes to hell
Jason X Freddy vs. Jason and Friday the
13th remake and Jason was the hero of
the Maine care yeah he's the guy that
shows up for the for the fights not it's
a tricky tricky [ __ ] question man
okay so now we've got [ __ ] tabulated is
that correct
well I you know I had a typo on the
answer sheet so Jimmy's retaliating oh
there's a different card is that all
right
cards have been swapped I guess we have
a winners at one winner or more than it
is one winner and it is with only one
incorrect answer what was the one
incorrect answer
no they got all the correct all of them
correct okay I got the part of her keys
there's another one man there's a tie oh
[ __ ] okay we have a tie that's against
my fault there's a typo on the answer
sheet
NORs mister poopy butthole team poopy by
mr. poopy bottle
get up here send a representative how
are you and what's the other team to
team discovering channel team team
Discovery Channel send a representative
up here right now alright man which one
is this on there it is what's your name
good sir speaking that Mike Michael
everyone give it up for my goal
what's your name good sir Gilbert what
is Gilbert yeah everyone give it up for
Gilbert you guys are gonna face off
against one another right here first one
slap the counter gets to answer the
question and the question is gonna be
asked by Andy right now Andy take it
away what actor plays the crazy patient
who shoots Bruce Willis at the beginning
of the sixth sense actor I know this
anybody that shoots Bruce Willis makes
it into your ass no takers anybody what
team are you are you on that team
the answer is Donnie Wahlberg and Bhagat
you win all right
nicely done and it's your birthday
what's your name Jen happy birthday Jen
you want a jaws poster give it up for
them well done all right man I'm [ __ ]
moving right along now we are into round
7 ladies and gentlemen and this round is
brand new we've never done it before
it's a very cheekily entitled round
called the Smithsonian Museum all of
these questions are going to be about me
and my work and [ __ ] like that and what
your what you're playing for is a signed
blunt man figure and in here is can you
pull that out please in there is a
poster a clerks anniversary poster that
was drawn by Steve stark of stark toons
who did all the animation for Jay and
Silent Bob's super groovy cartoon movie
[Applause]
and it was put out by the good folks at
upper deck this is an artist proof I've
signed it at the bottom it's a gorgeous
poster and it's going to be yours along
with this figure if you win this round
about Kevin Smith I have not seen these
questions so I'm gonna learn them along
with you and if I get any of them wrong
boy am I gonna be disappointed in myself
ready to go folks
empty cards and frontier phones down
pens in your hand question number one in
round seven
what was the name of Will Ferrell's
character in Jay and Silent Bob strike
back I know this what was the name of
Will Ferrell's character in Jay and
Silent Bob strike back number two on the
Leno Tonight Show what famous TV theme
just wow there's deep cuts
what fame nobody's gonna go I don't even
know this what famous TV theme does
Kevin fly around the Seattle Space
Needle too after having his first sip of
coffee we did a Tonight Show short a
road sign oh it's [ __ ] obscure man we
might have to swap do you have extra
questions like yeah let's you got that
question then it plays ladies and
gentlemen holy [ __ ] yes all right
that's in the DVD extras on Jersey girl
you could justify it all you want that
is incredibly [ __ ] obscure but if
she's got it then it's gonna play that'd
be amazing okay here we go number three
what is Kevin's mother's childhood
nickname for him what does my mother
call me I would get that one right
it's crazy I wouldn't get the second one
right at all I don't remember number
three what is my mom call me man what's
my mom's childhood nickname for me which
to be fair she still uses as Mia as a 47
year old man she still calls me [ __ ]
number four who played who played if
you're missing a word who played the
film-within-a-film
there who played the film
than a film version of Silent Bob in Jay
and Silent Bob strike back in the movie
Bluntman and chronic in Jay and Silent
Bob strike back who played the big
screen version of Silent Bob you know it
think about it and then our last
question in the Smithsonian Museum round
is what famous comedian inspired Kevin
to Don a trenchcoat and backwards hat is
an excellent [ __ ] question well done
sir what famous comedian inspired Kevin
to steal his [ __ ] look and wear a
trench coat and a backwards [ __ ] hat
that's the end of the Smithsonian Museum
round ladies gentlemen when you're
finished with your card hold your card
in the air and one of our fine
volunteers ago come along and pick it up
we got cat ears we got Nate we got Big
Daddy Jimmy B they're all helping us out
tonight give them your card and we're
gonna find out those are good questions
man I did my best sir I'm a little
nervous because you didn't review them
ahead of time but I know I was but I was
happy to not know them in advance it was
actually more fun yeah card collection
is going on ladies and gentlemen throw
your hands in the air wave em like you
just don't care someone will collect
your card and you will become eligible
to win this signed blunt man figure and
that sign clerk's poster from the good
folks at upper deck and I just found
something at the bottom and the monster
round aside from the jaws poster this
was the other prize man so come pick
this up it's a first season of our
zombie on DVD that goes with the jaws
poster you want something else birthday
girl well done all right
so we're all in with our cards all the
cards all the cards are in then let's
find out the answers to these questions
I don't even have to look at the key for
some of these what was the name of the
Will Ferrell character and Jay and
Silent Bob strike back ladies and
gentlemen somebody call it up marshal
will and Holly it is well done on the
Leno Tonight Show what famous TV theme
does Kevin fly around the Seattle Space
Needle too
after having his first sip of coffee
correct
holy-shit manly you know more about me
than I do
well done what number three what is
Kevin's mother's childhood nickname for
him anybody my mother calls me tiger I
know I don't know why like I wasn't my
god no it's a random she I guess she was
like if I'm gonna call him an animal I
might as well be tiger instead of pig or
something like wow who played the film
within a film version of Silent Bob and
Jay and Silent Bob shaken be a great pie
[ __ ] himself Jason Biggs ladies and
gentlemen whoo if I have my way if he's
willing to do it because the scene is
written for him both Biggs and Van Der
Beek return in Jay and Silent Bob reboot
that is brain okay last question of the
round what famous comedian inspired
Kevin to Don a backwards trenchcoat and
start where and the answer is Sam
Kinison well done and a love Sam Kinison
look excellent [ __ ] round of
questions give it up for Andy came up
with the [ __ ] questions for the Kevin
round the seamen's they're having a life
to make questions about well done kids
well done ok we got a winner we got a 5
answers correct winner only one only one
[ __ ] a man there's a winning team here
that answered every question right which
means you would have beat me if I'd
played the round that's so who is that
winner
it's the 37 Club there we go
come on up and get your [ __ ] man you won
what's your name concert Travis give it
up for Travis ladies and gentleman
well done that's yours that's yours I'll
take this he's a winner and off he goes
[ __ ] Travis well done the man who knows
more about Kevin Smith than Kevin Smith
okay here we go
the next round is round eight we're
closing it on the end of this [ __ ]
game what happens at the end of this
game folks is when we play all the
rounds every round of course has a prize
but when we finish all ten rounds
whoever wins the most of all the rounds
of the game like of those ten rounds
wins a one-of-a-kind Ejim a challenge
coin tell them what that edge of a
challenge coin allows them to do the
edge of a challenge coin allows you to
come to any future game and get a full
set of cards absolutely free ladies and
gentlemen and it's also like one of a
[ __ ] kind urine
yes lose of club man so yo you and very
few other people will have this [ __ ]
coin and you lose this use this [ __ ] to
get laid probably well just flip it in a
coin in the air like Harvey Dent all the
time people like what's that you're like
it's my edge of a challenge coin okay
what do we do star together you want to
talk about the prize for this one this
is the this is a big deal this round
ladies and gentlemen quiet folks here we
go just setting up what we're about to
do round eight is what we call the
Lightspeed round the castle round or
though that's right we changed it it's
better to call it the Kessel run round
eight is called the Kessel run round and
obviously that round is always going to
be themed with Star Wars universe
questions but this week the prize
normally the prize would be some Star
Wars [ __ ] that I got sitting around my
office but this week the prize is pretty
[ __ ] spectacular tell them what they
can win if they win this round
feel the force this summer with special
screenings of Star Wars a new hope
August 7th and 10th and the Empire
Strikes Back August 9th and 11th watch
the movie on the Hollywood Bowl
spectacular HD screen while John
Williams iconic scores performed live by
the Los Angeles Philharmonic and
conducted by David that's right ladies
and gentlemen the winner of this round
is going to get to
tickets to the Hollywood Bowl to go see
Star Wars a new hope man so you just
gotta know a bunch of [ __ ] about Star
Wars in this round is that correct that
is correct okay round eight is called
the Kessel run round here we go folks
get ready pens up phones down blank
cards in front and shut your [ __ ]
mouth
number one what does Yoda eat from Luke
supplies when he lands on Dagobah or
I'll save Dagobah take of a system the
Dagobert system what does Yoda eat from
Luke supplies when he lands on Dagobah
and Luke gets all fussy and it's like
you're making a mess yeah it's the quick
hint it's not his dick Wow
number two what tool does Han ask Chewie
for when he's fixing the Millennium
Falcon's hyperdrive
yes that was Chuy's response what tool
does Han Solo ask Chewbacca for when Han
Solo is fixing the Millennium Falcon's
hyperdrive that that's the question JC
wasn't a question that Rosie O'Donnell
gave me in 1999 that I won the trivia
contest on Rosie O'Donnell well anybody
used a JC fan you might know the answer
Wow hold on there's a lot of a lot of
unpacking to do with all of that I don't
think anybody knew anything about this
you on the Rosie O'Donnell show the
Rosie O'Donnell show on may 19 1999
which was a day episode one came out
doing Star Wars trivia me and what did
you win like a giant box of toys like
it's a me sized box of Jar Jar Binks
figures Wow
what I've known you for years the first
[ __ ] time I've heard this story do
you have any left can I have a Jar Jar
figure hey probably in storage you know
I'll bring some for the light and Kessel
run next week
sweet baby sickos could be prizes here's
some [ __ ] JC don't want
Wow that's [ __ ] wild man alright let's
see number three what is Hans callsign
when he's first scouting on his taun
taun on Hoth and the Empire Strikes Back
Hans on a tauntaun you hear his call
sign
what is Hans callsign when he comes down
no internet ladies and gentlemen no what
no internet please ya know in our town
but ya don't text don't ask you could be
asking for help for all we know you
could you're like I have to win that
[ __ ] cheap prize it's not worth your
dignity folks don't do it okay number
four if you couldn't get into Empire
when it was Empire Strikes Back when it
was in theaters you could always go see
this film that came out one week before
and it won the Oscars for Best Original
Song and Best Original Score named the
movie if you couldn't get into empire
strikes back when I was in theaters
that's okay because you could always go
see this film that came out a week
before and won the Oscars later on for
Best Original Song and Best Original
Score all you have to do is name it that
is a [ __ ] dick biter of a question
man it's obvious I'm gonna you know it I
don't even need to get the clue it's
obviously a musical it's obviously a
musical and absolutely right
okay the Kessel run here we go the last
question in the Kessel run you're about
to complete the Kessel run ladies and
gentlemen Empire Strikes Back was shot
at Elstree Studios in London at the same
time as what other famous film that came
out one week later parenthetically
speaking that film that came out one
week later won the first annual Razzies
for worst director and worst actress
so this is a very loaded question man
break it up into two parts just so you
can make sure you process it Empire
Strikes Back was shot at Elstree Studios
in London at the same time as what
they're famous film that came out one
week later and as a hint to what that
famous film is that film went on to win
the first annual Razzie award for worst
director and worst actress wow man
that's [ __ ] deep cut pull but I I
know the answer because you told me
before but I don't think I would have
gotten that answer oh there's an
interesting tied together at the same
studio at the same time so a lot of Star
Wars fans will know this film
alright that's five questions let's hand
in those cards everybody we have
finished the Kessel run put your hands
together ladies and gentlemen the prize
is two tickets to go see Star Wars a new
hope at the Hollywood Bowl if you've
never seen a show at the Hollywood Bowl
or even if you've seen every show at the
Hollywood Bowl it's a great experience
this is a really great prize package if
you don't finished out you're finished
your cards fit a little filling amount
put them up in the air man cow deers is
walking around collecting Nate's helping
around I guess Big Daddy Jimmy B is in
the other room tabulating of course so
throw them up let's get them collected
and let's give you all these answers for
this round man it's a fascinating list
of questions if you don't win the
tickets you can always go to Hollywood
Volcom and buy your own cuz you imagine
that like most places when you're in a
contest you can't like if you want these
you could go [ __ ] buy them - yeah you
can if you if you lose this round and
want to feel like a winner you can go
buy ticket to be like I want to work
yeah I won with my own money alright
anybody have cards and all the cards are
then here we go folks the answers to the
Kessel round round 8 here we go number
one what does yo to eat from Luke
supplies Bennett lands on Dagobah tell
us Andy he eats a granola bar also an
energy bar would have been acceptable we
will take energy bar or granola bar yes
it was an actual granola bar they used
in the filming I'm looking at JC to make
sure that up
it's okay okay number two what tool does
Han asked Chuy for when he's fixing the
Millennium Falcon's hyperdrive and of
course JC the answer would be hydro
spanner hydros manners we were looking
for man if you got that you're almost
close to getting these tickets number
three so yeah what is Hans callsign when
he's first scouting on his taun taun on
hop Andy its echo 7 echo based echo 7
echo 7 was the answer if you couldn't
get into Empire when it was in the
theaters you could always go see this
film came out a week before and it won
the Oscars for Best Original Song and
Best Original Score what is the name of
the movie Andrew becomes mu B is fame
fame ladies and gentlemen hey is it
gonna [ __ ] live forever yes
apparently not long enough for anyone to
remember that movie was out at the same
time [ __ ] number 5
Empire was shot at Elstree Studios in
London at the same time as what other
famous film that came out one week later
on and that film went on to win the
first annual Razzie for Best Director
worst director worst director and worst
actress what's the name of the movie The
Shining have you [ __ ] believe that man
they [ __ ] gave Kubrick a Razzie for
this [ __ ] shining they hated that
movie unbelievable I didn't even realize
those blue two movies were out at the
same time yeah that blew my hair back
well he's just a little what it's
[ __ ] yeah she's not saying you're
[ __ ] oh those Randy's like I'm not
[ __ ] did we get a the opposite of
[ __ ] yeah I try to be honest
authentic as I can do we get a winner
one we do and yes and that is the 37
Club 37 plug love win again come on up
send up a representative
nicely done sir what's your name
Travis Travis again give it up for
Travis ladies and gentlemen
JC tell us about the tickets that you
you look so perturbed no your name will
be on the guest list at the Hollywood
Bowl so I'll give you my business card
you email me and I'll get you set up but
so that you walk away with so you walk
away with something in your hands
we're gonna give you this these are
wardrobe tags from the movie yoga hosers
yes
now the everyone's like you but let me
literally show you what the [ __ ] that is
I was just gonna throw this [ __ ] out see
it says customer number one and on the
back it has all of the wardrobes listed
but I can't throw [ __ ] like that cause
I'm like this belongs in a museum
so this is going into your care man
you're a winner
I love getting rid of [ __ ] okay here we
go round 9 ladies and gentlemen is the
pop me in the mouth round this is for
the winner of this round is gonna win
this lovely little sign Kevin Smith
popped figure right there sold
exclusively at Jay & Silent Bob's secret
stash the comic book store in Red Bank
New Jersey Funko pop pop me in the mouth
round is pop culture questions yes just
any kind of pop culture question it's a
curse Bowie if it's a popper e13 it well
well said sir so here we go
pens in your hands blank cards in front
of you phones down and everybody silence
as we enter round 9 here we go number
one number one Taylor Swift James Corden
Jennifer Hudson and Ian McKellen are
going to star in the film version of
what Broadway show yes it was just
announced it was just announced recently
I heard it at comic-con Taylor Swift
James Corden Jennifer Hudson Ian
McKellen walk into a bar know these
people they're gonna star in the film
version of what Broadway show right
down because we're going to question
number two here we go folks quiet
question number two so everybody can
hear it what so everybody can hear it
what is Paul McCartney's middle name
what is Paul McCartney's middle name Wow
that's an electric charge wait I know
everybody was like unfair but some
people were like whoo I know that yes
very nice all right number three who
co-starred in the 1989 buddy action
flick collision course with Pat Morita I
know this
that's crazy great pull who co-starred
in 1989 there was a buddy action comedy
called collision course one of the
characters was Pat Morita yes Pat Morita
played one of the buddies I played one
of the buddies the other buddy
that's the name we're looking for man
who co-starred famous famous person very
famous person number four in season two
of stranger things
yeah the hushka oh I've seen that in
season two of stranger things what does
Dustin name his pet from the upside down
it sounded more adorable in a British
accent I don't know
and number five ladies Jim the last
question of the Funko pop popped me in
the mouth round goes a little something
like this what was the name of Rick
birdperson and squanch cheese band in
college yes together if you know you're
Rick and Morty that's a pretty great
question man very memorable name what
was the name of Rick and birdperson and
squanch cheese band in college Rick and
birdperson squanchy had a band in
college what was the name of that band
once you write that down ladies and
gentlemen
that is the end of that round put your
hands together we finished another round
all right hands up when you complete
your card holder card in the air wave it
like you just don't care cat ears Nate
they're gonna come pick it up Big Daddy
Jimmy bees gonna tabulate it in the back
and we're gonna find ourselves a winner
man I like that category it goes all
over the place yeah a lot of choices fun
we finally keep people keep people
involved no doubt and some of it was
current like you know [ __ ] that first
question was from this week
okay everyone handed in their cards
anyone still holding on any cards one
card over there any cards over there all
cards are in from this side counting it
down give you ten seconds to close out
the round ten nine help me out eight
seven six five four three two one
Happy New Year everybody okay man the
round is closed so now we're gonna go
over the answers to that pop me in the
mouth round winner of this round is
gonna walk away with this fine sign
Kevin Smith Funko pop here we go man
first question was Taylor Swift James
Corden Jennifer Hudson and Ian McKellen
will star in the film version of what
Broadway show Andy cats they just
announced it this weekend cats [ __ ]
[ __ ] is right
what number question number two what is
Paul McCartney's middle name I have no
idea it's Paul his first name is James
and his middle name is Paul
you were so happy about that you had to
come put it in his face your trick
question of sorts it's some well done
number three who co-starred in the 1989
buddy action flick collision course the
absolute correct answer how did you
[ __ ] know that you you've seen it oh
[ __ ] no it's a terrible that's
hysterical man okay number four in
season two of stranger things
what does dustin name his pet from the
upside down
d'Artagnan or dark for short we'll take
both we take dart or d'Artagnan dart or
d'Artagnan and then the final question
of the round which seemed to stump a lot
of folks man what was the name of the
band in college that was populated by
Rick birdperson and squanchy and that
would be the flesh curtains the flesh
curtains oh my god the flesh curtains if
you had that you're gonna be very close
to this Funko pop we have a card that
means we have a winner just one winner
is gonna walk away with this fine
Kevin Smith sign Funko pop ladies and
gentlemen Andy what do we got why that
team would be the ever winning 37 club
the 30 cent ladies and gentlemen what's
your name captain oh [ __ ] that one's
dead what should I have got John I won't
give it up for John yes
who knew that knowing watching that
movie would get you a prize let me tell
you something man John is living proof
that no time has ever wasted you watch
that movie and I'm sure somebody was
like why you watching this [ __ ]
[ __ ] what 20 years later that's why
you watch that [ __ ] well done man
all right ladies and gentlemen we were
about to enter round 10 of the edge of a
pop quiz this is it we've gotten around
ten we did twice as many rounds as last
week's give us your applause because we
accomplished something round ten the
last round of the game we call the shirt
off my background whoever wins this
round is gonna win this jersey that I'm
wearing right here man you will win the
shirt off my back you whoever wins I'll
take it off I'll sign it boom it goes
you can have a Sharpie standing by
please the name of the round is shirt
off my background and so thank you the
the idea is back is the word in play
last week all the questions were themed
- back to the future this week all the
thien's were gonna be themed - Empire
Strikes Back but we use those in this in
the Kessel run category so Andy said
what back should we do and then I said
well if it's good for my shirt if it's
for my jersey we should really make the
round hard so this round is gonna be
very difficult for you unless you know
the movie backdraft that's right or a
bunch of people going why don't I watch
it more backdraft
is the category ladies and gentlemen I
can't imagine any one's gonna get all
five right but if they do aside from
winning this Jersey I will buy your
around a team of drinks if you can get
all of these five right oh my right hand
imagine this is gonna this guy's just
like I can't believe I would install
collision course instead of backdrop
here we go folks round 10 is about to
begin the shirt off my back around the
category this week is backdraft
and question number one let me get your
silence
here we go what actor played Kurt
Russell's character's father in
backdraft in backdraft Kurt Russell had
a dad who played his dad yes
famous role for a specific reason I know
it's like disappointing everyone's I got
[ __ ] man is it hard but like you gotta
end it hard yeah that's easy and [ __ ]
easy questions from round one but round
ten is gonna be difficult
number two who hosts the line video at
the Universal Studios backdraft
attraction if you go up to Universal
Studios and you go on backdraft the ride
or whatever the [ __ ] they call it
somebody is hosting the video that you
watch while you're in line who is the
host of the backdraft line video now let
me something people saw it more recently
yes yeah probably okay number three
roughly how many real firefighters
appear in the film wow you're making
them work for this [ __ ] shirt this
was a variety headline it's at one point
is it really yeah okay
according to Variety roughly how many
real firefighters appear in the film
backdraft
take a number number four ladies and
gentlemen what former child star plays
the pathologist this is a former child
star and he plays the pup this is a
former child star who plays the
pathologist in backdraft oh my god I
fell across the room could you imagine
if somebody was like you've got to
answer five questions if you want to
live otherwise I'm gonna shoot you in
the head you're like alright that's fair
enough and they're like the questions
are about backdraft feel like you might
as well [ __ ] shoot me now man
there is there's a way to get to this
answer is there yeah you'll tell us
later on yes what former child star
plays the pathologist's in the movie
backtrack and the LAT backdraft the last
question of round ten lays on the shirt
off my background for the brac draft
category is who was originally cast as
Brian McCaffrey before Billy Baldwin but
had to do a small part in a Ridley Scott
movie instead I know it's [ __ ] it's
cruel is what it is you gotta know such
deep cuts he was cast in the movie and
could not get on out of his contract to
do a very small part in another movie
directed by Ridley Scott so wait he he
could not be in backdraft because he was
previously committed right to doing a
tiny role in a Ridley Scott cast as the
lead had to go do a tiny role ooh that's
got to hurt as an actor that's the last
question in the round ladies gentlemen
round 10 shirt off my back the back
draft category is what we look for if
you're done with your card
hold them up in the air Caviar's
everybody Nate
they will come along and they get Ridley
Scott movies once those parts go in
Big Daddy Jimmy B is sitting in the back
with a super complaint that one over
here and tabulate all the answers and
when the answers are when we find who
our winner is that winner is gonna walk
away with the jersey that I'm wearing
the [ __ ] literal shirt off my back
plate is gentleman and I'll tag it and
you can take it home and you can make 19
jerseys out of this one Jersey if you're
good enough oh come on are all about
cards not yet we have one more team with
a digit hangar card in right here in
seconds 10 seconds to close this round
counting now 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 we did
it ladies and gentlemen we finish
something not only did we finish it
round but we also [ __ ] finish the
game ladies and gentlemen but first up
we got to do is go through the answers
while all the cards are getting
tabulated in the back let's walk through
this perilous [ __ ] back Travis that
was your request and really I did
request and I don't regret it I know I
know it's disappointing for a lot of
people I don't know [ __ ] [ __ ] about
back Jeff well if you're ever going to
come play the pop quiz again you know
how to load up for the last question it
usually has something to do with fact
that's right so you know I figured that
out maybe reverse engineer nobody was
ever gonna look for back yards don't
know that much yeah I was surprised
myself I know that he goes what should
we do I was like do him about backdraft
and he just sent back a question mark
here we go number one what actor played
Kurt Russell's character's father in
backdraft does anybody know no it was
Kurt Russell played both his himself his
character and his father character wow
man that honestly makes me want to go
watch backdraft tonight yeah oh it's a
trick question
I don't know anybody got that right
number two ready who hosts the line
video at the Universal Studios backdraft
attraction Ron Howard is the correct
name towards the answer man well done
alright you know that would have been a
good guess and I wouldn't have even
guessed that [ __ ] good number three
roughly how many real firefighters
appear in the film backdraft Andy it was
5,000 there was a funeral in the movie
and real firemen marched because they
wanted to represent their uniforms and
in fact there was a suburban
firefighters came into Chicago and they
weren't allowed to March because they
were wearing the wrong uniform and then
like Leno March anyway but well then
yeah so everybody that came got tomorrow
the answer we were looking for is 5,000
I was gonna guess zero I thought it was
a trick question like there were zero
real firefighters but 5,000 [ __ ] okay
number four folks hush up we're giving
out answers here we go
[Music]
what former child star plays the
pathologist well if you're familiar with
Ron Howard's work you know that he casts
his brother Clint Howard in every single
movie in a cameo role and that was the
role he played that was clean Howard and
he was a child actor who was on gentle
Ben and also in a Star Trek episode yeah
he played the one that's like I like
Trent was a truant right Ron yeah I hope
you cherish it as much as I yes wow that
was a tough one and then number five who
was originally cast as Brian McCaffrey
the main character before Billy Baldwin
was cast
but then that actor had to do a small
part in a Ridley Scott movie instead so
he didn't wind up being in backdraft I
let me let's don't give it out let's try
to reverse-engineer this what was the
Ridley Scott movie let's start there
Thelma and Louise Brad Pitt Brad Pitt
holy [ __ ] man Wow that worked out for
him in a big bad way it became his
signature it really launched his career
so the ant are you kidding me yeah no I
was looked at there's two winners two
winners one correct holy [ __ ] say that
out loud all right folks listen up this
is important information we've just
gotten the [ __ ] round winners and
there are two round winners there have
to compete against each other for the
grand prize but in order to win how many
correct answers did they have in the
backdraft round each team got one
correct
[Applause]
Wow it is a [ __ ] it's a squeaker mr.
M that is so [ __ ] tight all right
tell us who the winning teams are and
the run representative from each team
join us up here at the bar who do we got
Andy top gun time gun is here
the 37 club give it up for the boys give
it up one more time what's your name
good friend Tom from from where Thomas
from Melbourne he came a long way to
play the game give it up for the
traveler yeah thank you and of course
we've seen you in the winner's circle so
many times give me your name again
Travis Travis is up again ladies and
gentlemen give it to him give it to him
hard okay boys you know the deal you're
gonna be slapping the counter cuz we
can't count on [ __ ] technology anymore
and [ __ ] this is like that TV show Jon
Favreau made powerless
I was thinking naked and afraid because
that's how I feel okay get ready to slap
the counter what is the is it still the
same category it is the same category so
this is they still have to answer more
back draft that is correct just when you
thought we were out of backdraft man
it's [ __ ] back ladies and gentlemen
okay so get ready wait for me to finish
the question and then answer by hitting
the table whoever hits first Kevin I'll
watch while I concentrate on getting it
right who plays the fire investigator in
in backdraft that calls fire a living
thing it eats and it hates Russell is
not the answer you have a chance to
steal and win a jersey that I'm sweatin
patrick saisi it was not trash Swayze
was not in bet he felt like but it was a
good guess I'm gonna give the answer
because we'll go on to another question
yes Robert De Niro that's right Robert
De Niro
we know we like backdraft okay so we got
a secondary question okay this one is
kind of something if you just think
about it and you think about the
questions we asked you should be able to
get it they're making backdraft - they
announced it two months ago what they
are making backdraft - are you [ __ ]
me not what do you mean why I mean I'm
just shocked like it must be in the air
I was like choose backdraft just think
about everyone in the movie there's just
all the people we've talked about so far
which actor upon announcing the movie
was being made immediately agreed to be
in the sequel not Kurt Russell I'm sorry
no I'm sorry come on man who's Robert De
Niro no it was Billy Baldwin he was the
one that was like I've been sitting at
home doing nothing oh my god that was
logical all right well done all right
hold on hold on folks settle down we
still haven't [ __ ] gotten the shirt
off my back so Andy's gonna go for a
third question but we're gonna take it
out of backdraft ladies and gentlemen I
hope that's okay with everyone oh really
you're back let's get you let's get back
to the theme of the bar so are you sure
I think we should stay in category
I think I got back Jeff yes all right
here we go this is the third attempt to
win my jersey get the shirt off my back
in the movie backdraft who plays the
psychotic arsonist that Robert De Niro
interrogate
the more I stare nothing comes out no
man give it up Donald Sutherland is
absolutely right
[ __ ] alright we're gonna have to get out
of back trip yeah let's get out of back
drive all right where you gonna go if
it's not back to it that's gotta be
difficult though to make it hard well
let's go back to his Star Wars everybody
let's he's gotta start where are words
very nice traveling around the world
showers here we go
so in Empire Strikes Back how long does
Yoda say he has been training at Jedi
Knights
how long has I'm sorry it's incorrect
not nine hundred years not nine hundred
no I'm sorry it's no 800 years it's 800
years ladies and gentlemen hey it looks
like I'm keeping my shirt yeah find
another one run one more I will do
another question this one hopefully we
will slide it to an easier zone here
what Frank Oz did the voice of Yoda what
famous female Muppet did oz do that is
correct
[Applause]
well done the reason it's a good start
was question is there's a little trivia
Frank Oz actually robbed Miss Piggy with
him to set and did it as a practical
joke and it basically came on to
everybody in the AMA cast as Miss Piggy
that's a true story
yeah [ __ ] what I mean he was the
Internet can use Miss Piggy to come home
to Yoda he can't know he was in the Yoda
scene but he switched it with Miss Piggy
and was like hey boys want to come back
to my trailer so oh really oh my god
that's fun oh my god you won the shirt
off my back give it up for him ladies
and gentlemen excellent [ __ ] job okay
man that's 10 rounds of the game and in
that means in the ten rounds of the game
there has to be a winner Big Daddy Jimmy
B is joining us I'm sure to let us know
who is the grant is there more than one
I
I don't think you understand when is the
we have a wooden spoon winner Oh
fantastic let's start with the wooden
spoon shall we yeah let's start a wooden
spoon can we got the wooden spoon
did anybody blow that up and [ __ ] we
give out a wooden spoon the wooden spoon
in popular this traditionally in England
is a wooden spoon look at the worst of
that thing
but this I'm not touching this is our
version of the wooden spoon it's a
gigantic raw blow-up joint so the losing
team walks away with this amazing item
because even the losers are winners here
the scum and Yemeni Cantina
okay so Andy so we have to thank them
with eight correct answers hashtag me to
hashtag me to takes the prize you guys
walk away with a giant inflatable joint
come receive it send up a winning member
of your team ladies and gentlemen Wow
what's your name my friend Bonnie won't
give it up for Bonnie she won the wooden
spoon
[Applause]
okay good sir what do we got left well
with the most correct the most correct
answers wait i Jimmy I need a quick
second to check big daddy daddy Jimmy
while those two confer ladies gentlemen
I'll just take this fine moment to thank
you all for coming out to the second pop
quiz and what now this is something that
we're gonna obviously continue because I
got a lot of [ __ ] in my office I need to
get rid of it's fun man it's a good time
I don't have to do much work I just have
to find some stuff put together and I
look forward to doing it but Andy's the
one who does all the heavy lifting all
the questions come from him and stuff so
give it up for Andy he's the one
responsible for your edge of a pop quiz
okay we have our winner mr. Smith we
have a winner so the winner of the night
ladies and gentlemen is the person or
the team rather that has won the most
rounds at the edge of a pop quiz today
they are gonna walk away with do you
have it handy can everyone see it where
as I do it's getting hot in my little
pocket the edge of a challenge coins now
they're eventually going to be metal
we're having a maid
like a real coin and stuff but until
then Andy handcrafted fabricated these
wooden edge a'mma challenge coins they
are [ __ ] glorious and when you win
one of these you never have to buy
another card as long as you live you
always get to play the game for you can
bring in a whole team of people up to
five and play for free man you could
turn this in for the metal ones when we
get them but this shit's so sweet I
might try to hold on to the wood ones
one of a [ __ ] con it's gonna live
right there handcrafted by mr. Andrew
but CalFresh and it's gonna go to the
winning team who is the winning team
Andy ladies and gentlemen put your hands
together for the 37 klein team comes up
and they win the second-ever edge of a
challenge cord congratulations boys
congratulations well done excellent
[ __ ] job the fact that you knew
[ __ ] Jay Leno was in collision course
that makes you legends in my [ __ ]
opinion did everyone have a good time
ladies and gentlemen I can't thank you
enough for coming out and [ __ ] it was
absolutely [ __ ] fun we'll do it again
I don't know is it next week are we
supposed to go again next week do I have
anything next week
look we'll put the details on Twitter
and [ __ ] like that is but yeah I think
we actually might and then I go back to
Jersey the week after that so we'll
definitely be doing this again if you're
free yes come join us again we'll kick
back and answer questions that Andy
comes up with once again man none of
this all my whole life is me going oooh
you know be fun and I say things and
stuff and unless somebody actually
builds them and puts them together
they're just dopey ideas that go don't
go anywhere
and the man stand to my left a
handcrafted everything give it up for
Professor Andrew McHale but not a real
professor and that is the active
vacation edge of a pop quiz for this
week I'm Kevin Smith and I'm aunt Eva
Kelvin and you have been edge of Makeda
good night everybody
[Applause]